first senior brother date a girl that
was bad for him yes yeah and what kind
of effects did that have on him a lot of
mental issues going in the wrong
direction choosing the wrong crowd to
hang out with well I can see that's why
you're a bit more selective with the
like because a lot of girls won't say
not to date single moms yeah but you
actually because you have brothers yeah
I've got three brothers and two sisters
yeah oh wow you're a big family yeah I'm
number five of six wow yeah the big
family
um but yeah so you can kind of see where
you understand a bit where they're
coming yeah because a lot of girls will
say no date The Single Moms yeah I get
their perspective day onto why they
would but then I would be like don't do
it because it's more stress on the man
correct